all right the first store we got is from
timcast.com New York City drag marks
participants chant we are coming for
your children actually I don't think I
can uh show the video because they're
nude so I have to turn on the blur here
that's cool and then uh yeah and then
let's see if I boot it up is it gonna is
it gonna blur it's not so let's refresh
and see if it worked now okay there we
go
all right
okay so the chance we're not going
shopping afterwards the fact that they
all know the change like they know what
this chant is it was planned in advance
they're saying we're coming for your
children here's what gets interesting
this is uh I think now I can remove the
blur this is ABC7 we're coming for your
children video of NYC drag March parade
stirs outright show even the corporate
press is covering this podcaster Tim
pool shared a video of the event I mean
technically I did it was Tim cast news
filmed by alad eliyahu several outlets
including the Daily Mail and Newsweek
have reported the videos from New York
City's Pride weekend people can be seen
in the video walking through a park
wearing colorful apparel some dressed in
Dragon others topless and they're
chanting that they're coming for our
children
at a certain point it's not a joke that
video came out a while ago from the San
Francisco Gay Men's Choir singing we're
coming for your children and people were
like hey that's alarming and what did
the media say it's a joke they're being
silly and it's no they're not joking no
they're not they they actually mean it
there are numerous videos going around
right now that I can't show on YouTube
one of them depicts a man and tidy
whities spreading his legs and
cheeks in front of children and then
gyrating and thrusting himself at the
kids
I can't show you that video I mean it's
hard enough to describe on a show like
this
Twitter is censoring these videos
if you try to retweet it they're getting
suppressed people aren't seeing the the
posts and then the videos themselves it
says this tweet is unavailable and this
is the scary thing about censorship I
understand you want to censor this so
that kids don't see it
you put a sensitive filter on it you
don't make it impossible for people to
see because the fact that people can't
see this is what's prolonging it so when
you go to someone and tell them this is
what they're doing this is what the left
has been doing they're grooming kids
they say prove it you try to find the
video the video's gone because Twitter
is censoring it out of a fear that
advertisers will play the platform no
that's exactly right there the lefts the
the transgender movement the left's best
argument for the past decade or so when
it comes to our kids has been it isn't
happening right just a straight up
denial that there's anything going on
with kids and that's all started to
change ever since all of everyone has a
tick tock Channel everyone has a YouTube
channel and because these kids are
bragging about it they're bragging about
getting double mastectomies and and
we're seeing this stuff in our kids
schools covid was awesome Silver Lining
to expose parents to what their kids are
experiencing but no that's exactly right
to him they we have to be able to talk
about this stuff and we can't protect
it's already out there I mean they're
they're doing this on the pride praise
the pride parades have been out of
control for at least the last decade
right like this is not new I've been to
Pride parades they always have weird
nude crazy stuff going on the leather
they've had the puppy guys you know out
there there's always been a level of
weirdness to this and um and at the
center of it right trans rights you have
it like they have special privileges now
right like I'm not able to go into the
streets and dance naked in a you know a
St Patrick's Day but that's pride in
general that's always been that way I
mean we've talked about it when I was a
kid you'd go to a pride parade and they
would be doing gratuitous things they'd
be naked so more more uh more
specifically when I was a kid my mom did
not let me go outside during Pride
because we had a cafe on North Halsted
in Chicago the pride parade would come
and just say go inside and don't come
outside because the things they were
doing
when I was uh maybe six seven years ago
in La people I knew in L.A were like oh
yeah when pride comes around they were
talking about how they all got naked and
would run around run around fully fully
nude it's like I'm like isn't that
illegal and they're like nobody cares
it's like okay well look at the people
in the cities don't care does someone
care I mean the the thing is maybe they
haven't been vocal maybe they have been
kind of like worried about what their
neighbors would say or whatever because
of the tone nowadays but I really find
it hard to believe that people don't
care I think people were afraid to say
something because of the fact that they
felt like they were going to be
ostracized when in reality they probably
were still the The Quiet Mind uh
majority most people don't want their
children to be exposed to to kink in the
streets of a major city and I think that
the stuff with uh Bud Light and Dylan
Mulvaney finally gave your average
person the courage to stand up and say
hold on I don't really approve of this
you know I want to see I want to see a
little more modesty in public no one's
talking about going into your
bedroom and deciding who you can sleep
with or can't sleep with or at least the
average person I'm sure there are some
some religious people that want to
you know want to get into the into the
business of what is going on in your
bedroom but the average person that is
just kind of living their life and
doesn't really pay a lot of attention to
politics they don't want their kids
exposed to nude men in the streets what
about like a dude in a diaper with a dog
helmet on
[Laughter]
that could that you know I bet you the
the average guy the welder that welds in
sin in uh South Dakota he probably wants
his kids to be exposed to a guy in a
diaper with a dog like a guy can go
shirtless in tight shorts any day of the
week walk down the street he can put on
a dog mask he can walk down the street
but like if he puts on a strap you know
fake strap on it or whatever now it's
becoming sexual technically Oreo a real
one but like I mean how is like wearing
a diaper as your only thing not sexual
for an adult anyway it's weird it is
sexual and it's all Kink though that's
the part of the thing is that that Tim's
talked about before is is this isn't
about actually being proud of your
sexuality it's about exhibitionism
narcissism and kink yeah well and I I
also think though that it makes sense
right this is a movement built on pride
and that pride has now turned into
hubris to where they're pushing
transgender bathing suit for little kids
at Target and they didn't think there
was going to be a consequence they what
those were adult bathing suits no no
they didn't they expose that it was for
for little kids no those were adult
bathing suits so they they did have kids
clothing and like onesies that said like
pride and things like that the tuck
friendly bathing suit was was an adult
bathing suit okay so the thing is though
regardless of Target did that right but
they're still trans kids stuff sorry
real quick the funny thing is like that
was the defense we got from the
corporate press like no no no that that
section where they're selling the kids
club that has all the stuff on it the
bathing's for tucking was for the adults
in the same section and it's like okay
I'm glad you brought up hubris man this
is um pride is on my mind a lot and like
how it's a Catholic sin but an American
virtue and I think this whole we're
coming for you rhetoric is hubris stick
like who do you think you are right
let's co-exist with me and threaten that
you're gonna come for my children it's a
celebration of a conquered religion
every year when Pride goes out and when
they are out there in the street
celebrating they're celebrating that
they have they're celebrating creating
their victory over Christianity and I'm
an agnostic I'm not the guy that's gonna
sit there and say he's a little too
explicit for me but you think I don't
think it's over Christianity I think
it's just I I don't I don't it's it's we
refer to focus as a non-theistic
religion but it's amorphous it is it is
it is boundaryless borderless it is just
it's more of a celebration of likeness
these are people who are going out and
being like we are we we have a social
group that's all they're saying
there's no logic there's no rules
there's no morals as long as you agree
to adhere to the group you're good if
you deviate in any way you're bad
they're not celebrating a deity they're
not celebrating an ideology they're
celebrating an amalgam of various social
theories and aspects mashed together
which often contradict each other I
don't disagree with you in that point
but I do think that they're celebrating
a victory over what is considered normal
or what has been considered absolutely
absolutely but Christianity like I look
if you go to these events they'll tell
you they don't like Christianity but
they couldn't tell you anything about it
and it's not in their minds yeah it's
the Christianity that Jon Stewart told
him who's out there and that's where
they get there they're not going out
there because of Christianity they don't
like it but they do like Islam
seriously like not all of them but a lot
of them do until they find out how Islam
feels about them nope they still like it
nope they'll move on just like that they
will move on the dialectic will continue
because as soon as Islam becomes the
conservative in their eyes then they
will move on just like they do to gay
men how gay men aren't you know you're
not queer enough if you're a a gay white
male like you're not queer enough and
you you get left behind that's what
happened to people like Milo and and but
it's it's you know Brenda striking
Prince Rick as gay man and and people
like it's been it's been years since uh
we've seen Islam uh Muslims protesting
lgbtq stuff like and then they're still
very much like oh it's fine it is
starting to change though there was uh
up in Michigan that's Dearborn yeah it
wasn't in Dearborn it was a town near uh
uh Detroit not necessarily Dearborn but
probably close enough suburb where they
said no Pride flags on public display
and they said because we don't put
anyone's flags on public display we only
do the American flag or or the flags of
Nations and then they got mad about it I
saw
um in the UK government buildings are
flying the the progress pride flag in
the U.S this is a flag it's a symbol of
a global
it's it's a it's a global takeover it is
it is a non-theistic religion it is a
global cult the fact that foreign
countries are flying this flag says a
lot the fact that you fact that U.S
embassies fly the flag says a lot it is
creepy and it and it should not be
allowed so I look I don't know if we'll
get anyone in Congress to be like hey
you know you can't fly flags like this
you know on government buildings they're
doing it anyway I can't speak for these
other countries but it is creepy and I
wonder
when I see that I'm like is that the
flag of like the One World Government
you know what I mean like not literally
in the sense of One World Government but
is that the flag of the Cross borders
internationalist ethos
it's at least the flag for the activists
that will get us to a One World
Government right like they'll have
something else more generic that appeals
to more people but I I like that idea of
passing laws that say that in in
government buildings you can only fly
government Flags right like the the
American why is it like what is their
argument against the American flag being
the flag that they hate America I I
understand that but like if you're on TV
right so like the professionals what do
they say because the American flag
really does represent everyone gay
straight trans whatever
whether you like it or not it represents
America so like why don't they just fly
the American flag like if I was an LGBT
liberalism yeah they they hate
liberalism they hate America
so it repulses them yes
and here's the crazy thing too there's a
video I saw out of France where during
their pride March someone climbed up to
a second floor about someone second
floor balcony and ripped down the French
flag it's not just America it is these
all these countries having some kind of
weird shared internet cult and they're
they're they're bubbling up in a bunch
of different countries the patriarchy
they want to smash the picture for sure
the white privilege no I think is what
it stands they are the pages times ten
like remember literally wokeness is
Hardcore patriarchy yeah
at the the the the advocacy against the
rights of women is it's crazy it's
racist too it splits up black kids and
tells them their skin color means
something like people become racist and
they're like so so so counterproductive
it's wild wild that humans think that
this is something thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time